you know you know why I think I'll get
banned because if you look at the
mainstream media what do they say don't
question the government young citizen
the government is always right unless it
came from Trump that's really what it is
it's weird it's like a good point yes so
no so when the government says vaccines
are good the meteor says well the
government said it therefore it must be
true like what happened to the days of
like we don't trust anyone in the
government or or trusting anyone at all
until you do your own research mmm
that's my favorite thing is do my own
research I want to find out all the
different sources I can and and
sometimes I mean even wrong right it's
okay yeah you know if I you find out the
best stuff right now I'm on YouTube and
there will probably you know take cuts
of this and be like you know accuse me
of being anti back for something that
doesn't owe a lot of people there was a
hammer burr who this was but there's a
celebrity who said that you know
vaccines are good veterans are important
vaccines save lives
it's one of the greatest accomplishments
and medical technology of the past
hundred years but we should question
government-mandated Mac vaccinations and
then also and all these stories popped
up saying anti-vaxxer anti-vaxxer
anti-vaxxer sponsorships would be like
you like you're totally going after
their career because nobody wants to be
associated with that's that smear
campaign yeah okay yeah but what are we
supposed to just be alike I think
everyone should just get the mandated
injection from the government it's a
scary premise because where does it end
it doesn't it's not gonna exactly it
keeps happening it keeps getting worse
and I wonder where the breaking point is
like I've never seen I've never seen it
this bad I wonder if there's something
else we don't know about but I don't
know what it would be like I have
evidence I'm not gonna speculate I think
you might have might have shed some
light a little bit on it it's the
pharmaceutical companies wanna they want
to be the ones that make the money off
of whatever we do from this yeah now why
wouldn't they I wouldn't even call it
necessarily a conspiracy that's like
exactly how business is running as
necessary and that's what they've been
doing for quite some time like yeah how
is it anything new actually it's not so
now of course they want a piece of this
so they'd lobby for a vaccine they would
they write they'd a worldwide pandemic
everybody's affected because it's novel
money need to be made yeah I see they
see dollar signs you know that's all
they see scary oh I mean yeah but can
they get it out fast enough
is like where where I don't know man I
think the system can only handle so much
and I I see people going for walks every
day outside me - yeah how long until
some cop walks up and just shuts him
down because in South Jersey there's
stories like several people getting
arrested for doing just that seriously
just walking around just walking around
I don't understand now back talking like
one of the stories I read was that was a
couple people were walking and the cops
rolled up and said hey you need to go
home oh man we're at them and they
yelled back I don't need I don't need to
do anything you know yeah like I don't
need to go for anything oh I just swore
there you go
that's it we just got we just got
totally dumont eyes out whatever I care
yeah all right but yeah they swore at
the cops and then all sudden the cops
arrested somebody that was an actual
quote right that's what you're doing
yeah you were actually toting them quote
yeah well we did just get everything
completely to monitize but I'm not gonna
cry about it you know what man I'm tired
and we're dealing with with the
apocalypse dystopian nightmare all
rolled up into one
I'm sorry and people for swearing it was
newsworthy you know it doesn't matter
YouTube doesn't care no but I I mean it
man I I'll tell you what in a week what
happens if cops are going door-to-door
and arresting people for some stupid
reason no one thought we'd get to the
point where a cop would arrest somebody
on the beach you know for no Regus like
for walking or attempted to arrest them
no I just mean we've we've seen all the
stories the guy in the paddle boat
yeah the paddle like nobody thought if I
told you that in January then the cops
would randomly grab someone saying
you're not all to be outside they'd be
like shut up right like come on yep ten
years ago you said look down Trump's
gonna be President yeah I'd be a
worldwide pandemic you're not allowed to
go outside unless you get a vaccination
card issued by the government immunity
card or you'll be arrested for going
into public people would be like get out
of here that's funny I was like yeah
that's where we are right now I was
looking at Amazon and I camera what
movie it is but it was like the movie
was made in the 80s and it was like in
the distant future of 2013 like the
world isn't like in rouen or whatever
instant future and I'm 13
seven years ago nothing happened I don't
know all those movies right so many of
them that the past is their future yeah
yeah yeah well they always thought the
year 2000 would be crazy I remember
seeing this comic of what they thought
the year 2000 was gonna be like and it
was like firefighters were flying like
yeah they what did we do wrong man we go
wrong yeah like in the reserve jetpacks
yeah obviously my flying car I want a
jet back the past generations had such
high hopes for us
yeah it's 2020 and what do we have we
don't real justice social justice we do
have cars that can drive themselves no
you know what we have complacency yeah
yeah I think that's that's a bit of
people are comfortable doing nothing
they're not striving to further the
human race anymore
I blame video games really you know that
was there was this that there's a quote
that I love that says if humans ever
meet extraterrestrials they'll shake
hands not because they overcame nuclear
weapons but but but because they
overcame the Xbox I know the quote was
in it it's in reference to we evolved a
certain way to chase after certain
things we love fatty sugary foods right
okay so we chase after these things and
we mass-produced them to our own
detriment we end up as morbidly obese
Americans we get sick we get heart
disease and we end up dying some people
resist some people exercise and do
better and you know because it feels
good as well but that's also another
issue dopamine so we create video games
that simulate goal completion and now
we've we've actually mastered the
manipulation to get people to waste as
much time as possible on these addictive
games that's true I mean look Twitter
and Facebook they know they're the like
extremely addictive it's on purpose it's
just a different game you know why
Twitter won't get rid of the like count
and the retweet count MA that's the
addictive nature of it's the game how
many points can I get yet how many
followers can I get how many likes how
many we reboots you put out tweet and
you look at those numbers and you're
like oh I can do better
oh dude I mean kick yep I get mine from
skateboarding I go out do a trick and if
I succeed I'm like yes yeah new people
that say they don't play games and yet
their head
Twitter Twitter's it's a game Facebook -
what's the difference you play with with
other people I I play on the PlayStation
4
it's an addiction it's the same net to
be addicting yeah and so you know the
same with shopping shopping is very much
the same
they generally am the general idea of
this quote is you know maybe you know
Fermi's paradoxes mm-hmm it's a bunch of
different ideas about as to why we
haven't encountered extraterrestrial
intelligence okay
the idea being that you could do a
mathematical equation of how big the
universe is the how many planets can
sustain life as we as we know it okay
and then you know why why is it that we
have yet to find them there's a bunch of
reasons it could be because you know
we're the first that's one we're the
first intelligent species to harness
technology it could be because the
intelligent species doesn't use radio
waves so they're getting giving off no
signals and they're it's just we may
have already seen the planet with life
on it we just can't tell it because
they're wired technology yeah it could
be that the universe is so old that
intelligent life flickers like lights on
a Christmas tree lighting up and then
dying out and lighting up and dying out
or it couldn't be sense or it could be
something called the great filter that
every intelligent species at some point
comes across a filter that wipes them
out one of those is self-gratification
that instead of saying we need to
survive we say we need to feel good so
that seemed pretty prevalent right now
totally that's like everything we have
is decadence people don't know how to
grow food even if they want to do
they're not allowed to buy seeds well so
building shelter like if everyone was
just dropped in in the forest there's a
huge amount of people that would just
get wiped out
oh dude most of them yeah but the idea
in this regard is you know so we evolve
we are goal-oriented we get it we get
satisfaction from solving something you
know something in our brains we get
satisfaction from eating sugary and
fatty foods because they were rare and
it was like high energy density so it
was good for us these things helped us
succeed to this point yeah but now that
we've controlled it all what do we do
right into the veins Krispy Kreme
Doughnuts wads of sugar wrapped in sugar
soaked in fat sent right to your
arteries colorful images
for your two-year-olds on their Final
Fantasy 7 remake mmm don't bring that
into this oh I have to down don't you
dare make sure feel good it does I've
you're right
my storytelling no no defense then so
then what we had to do in the past when
faced with real challenges was scary
mm-hmm the bear emerges from the forest
panic what do you do well solving these
problems
you know completing goals and fighting
for your survival felt good and it
helped you survive and you had to do it
yeah now we're at the point where you
know while the animals anymore for the
most part sometimes a deer wanders into
Chicago and everyone panics or there's
one turkey in the front yard and
everyone freaks out what we've done is
we have you know we've wrapped ourselves
in a self gratification cocoon yeah so
now we'll bubble but now here's the real
challenge we've evolved to survive on
this planet in this planet's conditions
mm-hmm if we need to go to other planets
we don't have any evolutionary
development in our minds that that's
saying go to Mars some people just want
to do it it's their right because
they're smart people who can think ahead
and see the future okay but in terms of
the immediate self gratification
no way man a Twinkie solves that right
away yeah look man if I want to feel
good and get a dopamine trigger I can
try and build the rocket over 20 years
or I can eat a Twinkie that's why people
are just greedy they want they want
Pierre yeah yeah that's that's basically
all well so that's it that's one that's
that's what the point of the quote is
basically yeah that humans might wipe
themselves selves out because we're more
interested in the quick easy feel-good
then we are the long-term you know it's
it's humans want short-term gains they
don't want to deal with long-term gains
yeah it's like I got away three five
years fit not interested so that what
ends up happening is we build a bunch of
dumb stuff on the earth grind it to -
you know - a it's discs or rotting and
withered and then some smart people may
have built rockets and you know gtfo
land on Mars the mother planet the rest
of us most of us just want the quick
that's quick dopamine trigger that's
that's
the work the whirring great filter you
know yeah and and you know what's even
worrying about it I guess as well maybe
maybe there's some weird authoritarian I
didn't like at the end of the tunnel but
there's another thing if governments
start coming around and saying like you
must do this you must do that and people
are like no I got Playstation yeah why
am I gonna resist
I feel good playing you know this video
game or watching this movie or eating
these these you know Krispy Kreme
Doughnuts I don't know people seem to
not really care about like you know
voting anymore yeah like young people
don't vote maybe they don't care anymore
maybe the goal with Biden
uh-huh was they were trying to make
everyone give up maybe may the dancies
like how can we get people to just stop
caring yeah just give up Ram Biden down
their throat and all sudden people are
like dude I am so out I do not care
what's I mean maybe because think about
how the culture war was was was bubbling
up like it was kind of scary right yeah
yeah like even I was being bullish on on
civil war that's all changed now the
corona virus pandemic but I was saying
like you look at these factions fighting
in the street what do you do well the
DNC Rams Biden down everyone's throat
they should give up they stopped caring
and that simmers things down I guess
yeah I guess
oh man thanks for checking out this clip
from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the
show live Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. if you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or check us out on
iTunes and Spotify and we will soon have
this podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you